go i two years ago I judged Miss America
and this lovely lady one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know it's funny I was I was just as
I was turning the corner looking at this
I was like [ __ ] man I really miss 2011
Vayner a little bit more like the same
thing that's you know it's MOT we
started this company literally within
weeks of my daughter being born and
literally this the other night I put her
to bed and I saw a picture of her when
she was like three and I was like [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] like older people tell me
like enjoy it this and that I was like
yeah like you just she's just not like
my daughter seven going on sixteen and
so and that's kind of like weirdly I
just had that same exact feeling turning
the corner here I'm like [ __ ] man
controlling fifty or sixty personal
feelings and like the mission is really
easy and fun compared to what the
[ __ ] insanity we're dealing with
right now so let's try stuff it's gonna
be a great year it's gonna be a great
great year last year was give room so
what I love to do is like go and then
clean up and then focus last year was go
and Justin smiling cuz he saw it at Wine
Library too when you go from 30 to 70
like you go oh my god
we made a local commercial that's right
I mean I we produced him and we [ __ ]
it killed the commercial we made a
commercial I forgot
hey we're ready executives at eye level
blind taste over 500 new bottles of wine
each month
first is the 2002 Sharpshooter Cabernet
great color
let's bring in 400 cases next is the
2002 blue harvest Merlot that was bad
what's next winelibrary.com tasting bad
wine so you don't have to
do you mind if I take big jalebi I
prefer it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everything is predicated on being the
bigger woman and man in every single
situation always and then using me as
the outpost I mean we can win real big
and I'm willing to do it and now I've
clawed - oh [ __ ] I can really do it like
literally trying to get into a place
where you're the bigger person in every
situation and then having a place where
you can take that poison out because you
want to get it out you have to eat it is
how we built Bane originally for real
that's how I got the right foundation at
first like just getting everybody
religious about I would be the bigger
person like I disagreed but I'll be the
one that bends right now but then I'm
gonna go punch Gary in the face or Kelly
or AJ now now it's and Claude is much
better than the combination Kelly and AJ
like this is a real thing so that's
another thing just to think about cuz
I'm that's exactly what I want to say to
them as well I mean it's insane there is
no separate there should be no separate
I understand physically even how big
this division is leaders think it makes
sense but it's going to be a constant
pressure on everybody from me in a real
way starting very very soon to not let
that happen and so I'm glad and that I
think we had those conversations in the
summer you know 101 things that nature
that allowed some movement I think in
the fourth quarter is a preview to it
and I'm sure some pockets are good and
some pockets probably exactly the same
and that's okay it just won't be able to
be exactly the same bad very long thanks
guys have a great day hit me up if you
need me know
we start with anything I personally can
answer for either one of you to help
this
we're doing thank you brother
thank you that's great I mean we've got
unlimited sorting capabilities like your
companies exactly the kind of people
that we can help the issue with
companies of your size normally without
knowing the details you know that they
think of social and digital media as a
secondary thing and they're they're
allocating dollars to PR or Direct Mail
or other things that then usually gets
them into a place where they're not
putting the money I don't care if you
spend a dollar a dollar with vaynermedia
if we can figure out how to take that
dollar and do something I will do it
it's that's not what bothers me it
bothers me that you're spending a dollar
with us when you're spending six dollars
elsewhere on things that don't matter as
much in 2017 and that's the thing on a
call like this or with a board or a CEO
or CMO or a head of marketing that I'm
always trying to have the first
conversation around because every dollar
we don't have is less things we can do
for you that's just common sense and
when you're and so and so a lot of
people gents or like oh let's test a
little something like this is a real
thing this is the communication of human
beings in our society today so the only
thing I would say to you is look the
make the biggest commitment financially
emotionally strategically that you can
to this and if that's a dollar Mazel Tov
but that's that's the way to think about
put
nice to meet you Richard real pleasure
your phone's dead
yeah my phones they're actually draining
let me call you back interview on
Breakfast Club
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna hook you up man
really hook you up force to be aught to
be honest to be honest I'm thrilled I
mean I was so upset two weeks ago and
this thing looked like there gonna be a
three or four scene which means they
were gonna sell there with a sign DeRose
they were gonna like this needs to blow
up they need to get rid of everybody
they've got to see one way to do it all
the way back put yourself in a position
to go all the way this way doesn't
happen all the way back like the Cubs
finally did it cuz Theo knows what he's
doing you [ __ ] go all the way down
get all the assets now they could get
hurt
like you it doesn't mean you're gonna do
it but like next year the gesture going
sixteen and force it in the best way
they can because there's two two three
big time quarterbacks coming out and
it's the year but classic Jets they'll
probably go eight and eight not get one
of the three kids to get all the
leverage before the moment people like
but you don't have to the Vayner you
don't have anything like nothing idiot
like in one year you're gonna come back
here and be sad cuz I said and that's
what happens so like I believe it you
have all the equity
[Music]
[Music]
in the same way that I talked to big
versions of this CA a rock nation I'm
like look we're all gonna compete on
everything
everybody's gonna compete on everything
because it's all colliding so to me I
think the thing to really have a serious
conversation about is how do we navigate
it so that it's Co winning instead of
like inevitable bumping heads like we
new brands we do sports you know I'm so
pumped I'm so hungry cuz I was like [ __ ]
you put me through so much put me
through so much [ __ ] why can't I eat
it's my full-time health trainer are you
here I want the bragging that text is
unusual for you what happened something
good happen did you text me you enjoyed
it yes I do DME look man I think that I
that me and you guys see the world the
same way and I think that we've been
executing against that world longer so
we're further along and the truth is
like nothing would make me happier than
to be a match for what you guys are up
to at a macro level and it could take a
million different forms but I'm super
not scared of it do you guys want to sit
here for a month next my team to learn
everything I'm crazy I'll give away I'll
give you all my milk I'll give you my
cow I just think it's all execution
Lindsey he need to get into the bigs and
find a method to steal they don't shape
huh sneaky
hey guys all right how are you good to
see you really well hello
oh it's wine Wednesday hey guys
[Music]
[Music]
give any big shout out to Ryan Colin
sorry I [ __ ] up I didn't see that you
made that video thought there was a team
I just tagged you on the post and I love
you hello kind of what do you want I
love the man love it
pumped I want the t-shirt now get it on
the t-shirt say I'm ready
what [ __ ] Gary course I realized I
mean boy I did yeah for two weeks that
we went to five six days to think Beulah
with my wife I got it right this time
thank you
and the kids yeah and no two four five
days we had just us which is a real cool
thing I had to ask myself some very
serious questions why am I doing this
it's very important to know if you want
to end up somewhere you have to know
where you want to end up then you have
to have a compass of knowing how to
navigate so for me it was it an artist
or famous I know I wanted to be an
artist nothing against fame by the way
it's just which one do you want is an
experience for your life I wanted to be
an artist so every day I made decisions
based on being an artist not being
famous or rich and the other kind of
interesting caveat is I was offered a
million dollar signing bonus and I
turned it down
glad we do this man I've been looking
forward to it like if I could do what
you did
I'd be the [ __ ] I'd be real [ __ ]
famous because I really understand
distribution it's the ideas I just gave
you it's not how people are thinking
people always take the easy way out the
easy way out right now is make something
hot let's put on [ __ ] SoundCloud and
Spotify and hopefully something pops
[ __ ] hopefully right right like
distribution of course music I want
people to hear it
what one one thing I'm really good at is
knowing what like normal Americans that
aren't into music will like because I'm
actually that I'm not a good I'm not a
very good music person I'm being serious
like I know that for a fact boy do I
really understand America so I know
Billy Williams like I know that's a hit
I'm always right about that [ __ ] so like
get that [ __ ] song out I know it I
just know it because I'm that person
I'm not Boyd who really knows music I'm
being serious
do you understand like I don't know when
people like oh that artist is done like
I don't understand
I know hits Saba [ __ ] I've been
telling you I've been telling you
Chicago well my boy
[Music]
I am I want you on I follow you on
Instagram think I'm the other day I you
look like he's in husband yards I'm not
sure can I get a [ __ ] of you tour for
us it's gonna freak out with the heat
like Victoria you have to always he's
like you gotta follow up and then I
start fighting like a couple of days ago
this is awesome thank you so much well
John there's great thank you for you
really thank you so much wish him luck
I mean what's his name Jamal Jamal yeah
[Music]
Jamal what's up man it's Gary B just
want to know him room for you man get it
get it I'm proud of you do it so nice to
meet your wife and I hope you win
brother talk to you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm saying that some people means to
make tiramisu America and they think
that you were a dumb pageant girl and
some people may think of you Miss
America and want to do business with you
because of it what I'm busy
why did I say yes to Miss America
because when I was little we first came
from to America my mom and I and my
sister would watch it and it felt like
very like it felt like a very special
part of my life
yeah yeah that was also in a very
different place in my career even even
three years ago for you what was it
three years ago two years ago I've
judged Miss America and this lovely lady
one I'm kidding I'm kidding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my whole my whole things that go done my
dad's gonna be real happy pre [ __ ] am a
man thank you so much for the love this
like I said it's so weird that the
hip-hop artists that ended up blowing up
for you is going to end up being my boys
run
to me to me there's only like three or
four pillars a culture right music
sports and so I don't I don't know how
well you know Mike you guys know each
other Boyd got it so Boyd's incredible
like you'll get to know them like I put
up the money for Boyd to command Jerome
fortune it's so hard to have something
happened like it happened to you it's
hard to be LeBron it's hard it's hard to
even even where Dave's that right now on
the cusp like it's hard and the only
thing these kids are doing is either
trying to be Stef or trying to be you
and the reality is the math is bad
meanwhile like [ __ ] you can
make a hundred thousand a year if you
get your [ __ ] together and just focus on
this [ __ ] in addition go try to do that
but do this too and so that's what I'm
really passionate about I just think
that it's dope that you really care
about other people like just making in a
different way you know you know you know
what it is I'm good enough to get mine
like so like like I'm already like you
know what I mean like when you're good
you want other people to win too because
you don't need to tear down other people
[ __ ] you've got yours so I've got my and
I want other people to win that's how I
think about it are you gonna go back I
give back now so the kick guy by name is
Scott Harrison he did charity water
he caught me real proper once we're
having dinner like this Jam and he's
like I know who you are I'm like okay
what you know he said you're gonna make
a lot a lot of money and you're a good
dude and when you're 60 you'll start
giving it away I'm not I'm not for the
neck that's what he said you don't
you're not real
and so you get back you need agree these
guys and that's when he said it's just
like you meet somebody like you and give
them that same inspiration I'm saw a
person like I want
I'm gonna give that back it could be me
you know it could be anybody it could be
the next person yep we're just give them
that
yeah iteration I agree man I see what
how you moving I see other people you
wait
yep you inspire good energy I appreciate
that my man talking about you man
well let's let's just turn up you know
I'm saying like but next time let's go
like to some hospitals a few really
about this in and that's easy that's
easy I'll go tomorrow I'll change my way
I love that [ __ ] like you only live like
[Music]
okay
alright fellow Mauro I'm out
[Music]